palau
quand on décide de s'intéresser au
potentiel des produits marins du québec
une réalité nous saute aux yeux le
québec exporte de presque toute sa
production et les québécois mangent en
majorité des produits importés
on a absolument tout ici pour être
autonome en matière de bruit ça fait 400
ans que on pêche on emballe puis en
export l'histoire des pêcheries au
québec aujourd'hui doit être questionnée
on prend le large pour rencontrer ceux
qui veulent briser ce modèle en sashimi
ce matin
c'est quand même incroyable ces
québécois puis sera au même âge et soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon ok non là je veux parler au gaumont
le sera pas long les boys je veux gérer
un problème dure j'ai manqué la
livraison
vous reconnaissez peut-être colomb de
saint pierre la chef s'est installé dans
son village natal du bic pour mettre en
valeur les produits de la mer de chez
nous ça fait 18 ans que le simple fait
de vouloir m'approvisionner en produits
marins québécois est devenu un peu un
combat comme moi le disant j'arrive au
kilo buvant un petit peu de crabes mais
c'est tout vendu d'avancé c'est pas
quelque chose ne s'est pas un random ça
se fait même le tarif puis je vous dire
c'est que
c'est comme la roche dans body coach ou
marche le petit et qu'est ce qu'elle
veut je veux juste un peu et je vais
juste un peu de crème dans le fond
ça se change flottant 80 sur lovely dit
c'est difficile à comprendre les
pêcheries au québec on s'en est pas
vraiment occupés c'est des histoires de
quotas de loi fédéral et provincial vous
savez la situation du québec est
complexe donc tout se fait en sorte que
s'est installée finalement une offre une
demande qui se base principalement sur
l'exportation puis sur des accords de
libre échange de marchés en képi fac
c'est difficile quand on est tout petit
groupe comme ça
d'aller essayer de négocier
des petites quantités de produits marins
québécois c'est difficile
les huit merci a été trop faire la
bêtise large et celles des québécois
souvent ils vont faire
un fish and tube de la piaule ces noms
c'est c'est même plus une option c'est
non
entendre colomb de saint pierre ont fait
pas un très bon travail collectivement
est-ce que la situation est aussi grave
qu'elle l'a décrit on profite du passage
à rimouski du chercheur françois
l'italien avec son équipe il vient tout
juste de publier une série d'études sur
l'économie dépêche les pêches au québec
c'est comme si échapper un peu au québec
on estime qu environ 80% des captures et
pêche sont réalisés au québec sont
exportés et un peu plus d'être 20 3 84%
de ce qu'on consomme en produits de la
mer sont importés c'est une structure
économique qui date de très longtemps en
fait on pourrait quasiment dire depuis
le début de colonie française depuis que
des pêches commerciales donc c'est un
traître du modèle s'est établie il ya
plus de 400 ans piquionne de fil en
aiguille établit un cadre dans lequel se
sont moulées les acteurs se soient les
acteurs gouvernementaux aux acteurs
économiques la société québécoise
pendant des décennies le québec et les
provinces de l'atlantique ont exporté de
la morue et d'autres poissons de fond
les politiques gouvernementales
soutenait massivement l'exportation le
marché local c'était pas la priorité
quand les stocks de poissons de fond se
sont effondrés iql fédéral a imposé un
moratoire les communautés côtières ont
pris une méchante débarque l ont fait
les frais d'une industrie spécialisée
qui a frappé un nul il n'y a tout
simplement plus de poissons dans l'est
du pays et à partir d'aujourd'hui la
pêche à la morue et aux autres poissons
de fond est interdit dans presque tout
le golfe du saint laurent
[Musique]
aujourd'hui au québec on pêche trois
espèces en abondance le crav le homard
et la crevette pourtant il ya presque
une centaine d'espèces comme et steve
dans saint laurent comme c'était le cas
avec la morue avant le moratoire notre
industrie s'est spécialisée cette fois
dans les crustacés
j'avais dit les trop grands crustacés
québécois c'est un peu comme notre
pétrole si on ne fait que miser là
dessus tôt ou tard on va se retrouver
dans une situation va se retrouver gros
jean comme devant
on sait très bien qu'avec les
changements climatiques le réchauffement
des eaux la configuration des courants
marins il va y avoir des modifications
importantes dans la composition des eaux
et donc les espèces sur lesquels on
s'appuie principalement pour faire des
affaires dans le domaine des pages
est-ce que ça va durer encore 50 ans
comme ça je pense qu'il ya un risque
important il faut profiter du fait qu en
ce moment ça va bien pour diversifier le
modèle pendant que certains c'est
attendre qu à une nouvelle crise du
crustacé pour âge et niveau est trop
tard
une des avenues prometteuses serait donc
la mise en valeur des espèces méconnues
[Musique]
on va à la rencontre d'un pêcheur qui
souhaitent sortir du trio homards crabes
crevettes et quand on s'en va à la pêche
il faut se lever de bonne heure
là
bas des fois par un petit peu plus tôt
ça je sais que le soleil au fur et à
mesure de la saison on savait pourquoi
ce matin là on va aller faire de la mc2
simpson je suis je te montre un petit
peu le borgou aussi le que je mange dans
des fonctions à la fin j'étais malade je
suis
[Musique]
c'est parti
leur numéro
on s'angoisse
la banque iième selon pacha qui les a
vite évolué on jette la drague à l'eau
j'en ferai un crédit d'étude
[Musique]
c'est le bon moment de la journée de la
nature se réveille le soler solaire les
oiseaux et foot bassin qui viennent nous
voir les
bons côtés de la job
emmanuel pèse principalement de la
mactre de stimpson on en voit rarement
poissonnerie parce que les japonais
raffolent et achète presque tout ce que
le québec produit
[Musique]
et
il ya quand même des beaux spécimens
puisque je trouve impressionnant ça
c'est à peu près la taille minimale est
un animal c'est 80 mm 8 cm de largeur ça
prend pas de 12 ans 10 et 15 ans sur la
course était arrivé à cette table quand
même impressionnant que les gros qu'une
grosse une grosse comme cela on parle de
30 50 ans c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire
attention à la façon que le côté thé
glee ça correspond à 3 % de la biomasse
qui surgissent mme donc aussi bien qu'à
boston ouvrir en prenant trop pour cent
par année la ressourcerie nouvelles puis
au bout de trente trois ans mais il le
stock s'est recréé à nouveau le ce qu on
dit qu'c'est c'est durable à long terme
qu'est ce qui se mange la ddt qu'est ce
qui se mange donc pour l'ouvrir pasquet
vivante le au louvre par en arrière
comme ça il ya le pied qui est prise et
le sur toile en acier qui est reconnu
pour mettre sur les sushis à presque
tout le manteau avec les siphons
aimerais-tu goûter aussi donc on y va en
entier oh oui en entier en sashimi mac
des simpson
j'ai bon à 6 heures du matin
c'est quand même incroyable
que les québécois traders même on pourra
manger quelque chose comme ça
c'est un produit qui gagne à être connue
qui peut-être connu plus en région qui
reconnut en asie depuis
des années mais on a su ici produits de
chez nous pas loin puis quand même un
goût une belle couleur que c'est
excellent d'un bon produit c'est un bon
quoi du qu'il en est advenu
[Musique]
on
est-ce que tu comprends les pêcheurs
d'être allé vers le modèle d'exportation
à quelque temps c'est beaucoup plus
facile pour eux oui ben tiges c'est sûr
que je le dis dès fois chacun sa job
le pêcheur sa job c'est quand je passais
le dos 16h 18h quand j'arrive se
contente des charges et mon bateau puis
pas ma journée durant
déjà dépêché c'est beaucoup que de dire
qu'on leur donne un petit peu leur petit
peu le cpie compliqué parce que je
comprends et dynamique attractive
transformateurs lui aussi qu'il soit ils
soient beaucoup de ressources et des
employés et serrures des chaînes de
production
mais il faut que ça sorte quand des
acheteurs à l'étranger qui sont prêtes à
prendre des containers à prix d'or du
coup de volume mais
des circuits de distribution se sont
façonnées comme ça parce que encore on a
beaucoup de volume dans une courte
période de temps
bourgault
des distributeurs a réuni des ziban toi
aujourd'hui plutôt péché combien de
kilos de crevettes je t'achète tous deux
coups pour un pêcheur c'est vraiment
intéressant parce que c'est un souci de
moins le problème est que grande
distribution c'est qu'elle a des
standards assez élevé au niveau du
conditionnement de la régularité du
volume de la forme de la marchandise
donc il ya un enjeu de distribution plus
fine que artisanale différentes beau
justement faire connaître d'autres
espaces aux québécois il nous faut des
nouveaux mécanismes que les options les
distributions sont soupe qui ne
viendront pas
compétitionné directement avec les
grands filter parce que c'est pas
l'objectif l'objectif ce n'est pas de
commencer à tout chambouler l'idée c'est
de montrer que il ya de la marge de
manoeuvre puis pour ça il faut innover
hommage c'est possible
ça c'est l'info les bras
[Musique]
la grande déception je n'ai pas été
malade ou quoi
[Musique]
comme pas mal de pêcheurs emmanuel va
vendre la majorité de ces pêches de
l'été un distributeur mais il aimerait
renverser la vapeur et développe avec
son ami guillaume un nouveau projet
nommé chasse marée et voilà
ils ont transformé ce bâtiment en une
conserverie qui met en boîte les mac
trelly bourgault péché par emmanuel et
d'autres pêcheurs du coin les viviers
permettent de conserver à long terme les
mollusques pourquoi la concerne c'est
vraiment pour essayer de donner le goût
aux saint laurent lors que les gens
seraient approprié les richesses du
saint laurent
la pêche est saisonnière puis on sort
des gros volumes sur des courtes
périodes puis c'est pour ce que nous
autres on s'est dit bon c'est le fun le
ferai mais ce serait bien aussi de
trouver un moyen de rendre agréable de
consommer des produits de la mer tout au
long de l'année autrement que sous forme
congelés ou sous d'autres formes
[Musique]
c'est drôle de dire qu'on innove avec
une technologie qui existe depuis 200
ans mais c'est vraiment une technique de
conservation qui permet d'avoir des
textures des saveurs des goûts assez
incroyable
la brise un peu cliché parce que ça
coûte pas là concert on n'est pas dans
la conserve de dépannage là on est
vraiment dans le plaisir on est
passionné de la mer est passionné de
l'apéro nous autres actifs dans le fond
le but du jeu là ce serait que tout le
monde quand il au même titre que des
chips ou du saucisson la vendée le
réflexe de s'ouvrir une canne qui est
qu'on en consomme de manière conviviale
ce qu'il faut souligner puisque on ne
souligne pas assez c'est là où les
pêches domaine puis l'eau ou des
recettes monétaires généré par
l'activité sont très bonnes on a les
endroits où les trous de dévitalisation
sont les plus prononcées au québec
bio comme une activité que j'aime
énormément on débarque la marchandise on
transforme pour l'export pis la
communauté elle se dévitalise
le problème c'est pas tant juste les
pages le problème c'est qu'on n'ait pas
plus imaginatifs pour mieux faire jouer
les chaînes de valeur pour les
communautés
or si on est en mesure de trouver un
débouché commercial
intéressant à des espèces pas
commercialisés ou sous commercialise
actuellement on pourrait trouver façon
de structurer des grappes des petites
grappes entrepreneuriale autour des
principaux ports de pêche des moins gros
ports de pêche
avec l'idée de mettre en valeur ces
produits-là à des petites et moyennes
échelle puis le code de chasse mari est
extraordinaire là dessus comment faire
d'une activité saisonnière une activité
qui peut être structurantes à l'année
longue
même si le modèle actuel favorise
l'exportation certains pêcheurs font
tout de même l'effort d'alimenter le
marché local c'est le cas des manuels
qui se rend chez colomb de saint pierre
pour lui livrer des mactre de stimpson
kg pêché ce matin
vient pas de nom mais c'est
[Musique]
vraiment grosse s'écoutant
476 160
[Rires]
mais le team death encore sa croûte non
choix qui achètent tautou
ya juste moi et dieu
sait quoi qu'il était venu manger le big
mac l'année passée la l'atteint pas
la table
[Musique]
c'est difficile de proposer un nouveau
produit et c'est nul c'est ça qui est
drôle ce dernier qui sont prêts à payer
des fortunes pour ce mais nous on ne
connaît pas puisque difficile en plus de
dire à quelqu'un je ne connais pas ce
produit là mais ça vaut une fortune mais
je disais non tchèques sandro il
s'accroche mais tu m'étonnes ils doivent
pas aimer ce
[Musique]
ses complexes la pêche mais c'est sûr
que si on veut remettre la main sur les
produits de la pêche va falloir qu'on
s'engage puis qu'on investisse ça va pas
changer comme cela va falloir que tout
le monde participe au changement de
modèle puis changement de modèle c'est
le consommateur qui va payer un peu plus
cher mais qui va s'engager aussi à
acheter des poissons québécois sur du
long terme c'est pour ça que ça
fonctionne avec l'industrie parce que
l'industrie va pas dire du jour au
lendemain j'en veux plus de thon
poissons les autres c'est des
engagements qui ne brise pas ses
engagements c'est ce qu'il faut offrir
aux pêcheurs et aux pêcheries pour que
le marché se redirige vers nous
pour arrêter d'encourager été au québec
pas encourager pas un modèle
engagez-vous dans un modèle cette belle
différents encourager une fois de temps
en temps ça va pas changer les choses
ils vont pas changer
[Musique]
c'est bien beau de parler tout une mère
mais ça donne faim on est invité pour un
petit 5 à 7 aux saveurs du saint laurent
au menu poutine à la m ça c'est une
tactique on utilise beaucoup avec les
enfants essayez de mettre quelque chose
de connu avec de l'inconnu ça peut aider
à faire accepter un nouveau produit la
danse indienne et le produit connu et
lahm a créé le produit méconnu vous avez
tous vos projets mais ce que vous avez
un rêve en commande
on a tout le même rêve on est tout fiers
nous dans nos domaines respectifs du
territoire qu'on habite on veut juste
que ce soit représentatif et puis pour
qu'on sente nous aussi qu'on participe à
une culture du x tu regarde ailleurs
depuis les gens ce sont habiles culture
depuis des années des années sur des
produits puis un patrimoine s'inscrit où
on prend la mc2 c'est monsieur on a su
ici chez nous c'est le fun dit comme
pêcheur d'en prendre soin c'est de façon
durable ces fossiles aval aux ics
d'avoir le talent aussi des gens de chez
nous comme le talent de colombes pour
faire connaître le produit le fleuve est
plus qu'une voie navigable de ccc rempli
de trésors puis on essaye de mettre
notre brique à l'édifice là pour
contribuer à ce que ce qu'on serait
approprié ce qu'on valorise ce qui se
crée une vraie culture maritime pour que
on soit fier collectivement une forte et
fière tu peux même tu va consommer petit
va en vouloir tu vas faire attention
prend pour ton équipe comme aux
olympiques mais investit investi dans
une équipe si tu veux qu'à gang
faut que tu y croies le haut saint
laurent
[Rires]
[Musique]